yo yo yo yo quarisa guys quali sabbia e
sono qui con parlo inglese perché ci sta
selena di fianco che una grafica ciao
selena saluta saluta selena come state
ragazzi sono supercarico oggi fa caldo
bestia ma a fare il live quando fa un
caldo bestia è e ciò che di cui tutti
abbiamo bisogno per ora una mike e meno
male che le faccio io non le fate voi
prossima volta fate voi porca vacca ad
altro e schiacciate lo schiavo tanto per
cambiare tanto per cambiare benissimo
come che adesso qualcuno che si intende
di live mi spiega come è possibile che
questa roba rimanga all'inizio di tutte
le mie foto non è possibile non è
possibile né rosa lo sai più selena non
ti sto si indicando la spalla facciamo
una roba migliore ecco ecco questo è il
punto giusto
comunque sia mi spiego un attimo sta
roba nissena mia portata
ecco che il ragazzo quello che avete
visto ieri nella crosta challenge se ne
è arrivato a casa che ci aveva la selena
di cartone che era mi aveva regalato a
un raduno mai al sabri gamer non ha
portata a casa lui è la versione avant i
ragazzi vedrete la selena di cartone
sullo sfondo dei miei video lamento qua
l'ho appoggiata così che rimane in bella
vista non ri ma rimane dovrei bene
ragazzi cominciano quel che impedì oggi
ho deciso di fare visto che non lo
facciamo da un po in live di fare più
vicina questo perché a ieri non avevo un
cazzo voglia di registrarlo
quindi quando qualcuno non voglia di
fare qualcosa tipo noi youtuber in
generale
dico io cosa che faccio dico perché
quando registri video di registro quelli
dove montare sti caz
quindi quando non lo vuole registrare
che faccio dico bella li facciamo una
live così giorno dopo la faccio la live
che non avevo né montare né un cazzo
l'unica cosa che devo notare e selena
che continua a cascare per terra non
avete idea di quanto ci ho messo a
tenere in piedi per questa roba è fatta
di cartone ma malissimo c'è nel senso
non sta in piedi manco a pagarlo fa chi
è a bene non la tocco più perché può
essere tragica stai ferma è ferma che
dobbiamo fare audience che sono giuseppe
sorgi di tu col cazzo che facciamo
audience si vede live prima che cominci
a fare le cose belle
così almeno magari suo personale cosa
che hai lido a caso magari ti sto
facendo live ma non è in live e quindi
non nessuno vede un cazzo e in live si
vede porca eva non bello live ok se si
vede ciao belli ciao a tutti quanti
ciao a tutti quanti spero che da selena
sia di vostro gradimento
direi che possiamo cominciare con happy
with ci siete
sei pronto zia tu non hai mai visto
qualcuno non promette non conosciuta
anche happy l'ictus elena quindi siccome
non conosce neanche primis oggi fuori j
il tuo ragazzo ti insegna a giocare
adesso vi spiego il perché lo vedrete
molto spesso nei video siccome devo
insegnarle perché deduco che una [ __ ]
del genere non sappia neanche che cosa
sia un videogioco quindi da oggi in
avanti ragazzi nasce l'operazione selena
gomez for video games metà adesso dove
insegnava selena gomez che cos'è il
videogioco cosa che lei non ha mai visto
perché ha visto sono certi gesti
magari non le dico più se tanti come
stavo scherzando scena due by addio
c'era un inception bellissimo fa chi è
quanto le adoro ste cose selena presta
attenzione che non vedrai mai più un
uomo giocare così bene
mettiti qua mettiti qua
tu pensa che io starò ma la faccio tutte
le domeniche da quando ho aperto il
canale pensate come cazzo facesse ancora
vivo non lo so sei pronta zia vai con
happy wings ci siete la si vede ci si
deve perfetto non sono sicuro che si
veda ma si si si vede che nice
no perché mi chiedevo fare i magheggi
ogni volta per capire se si vende o meno
ragazzi primo livello di today sono
contento di farlo in live così poi non
me lo devo montare [ __ ] giangio
voglia di giocare a ping ci manca solo
che lo deve montare si stanno ora voglio
vedere ma se allora ma secondo te se io
apro happy wheels gioco ha detto mi puoi
mai mettere un altro gioco se volevo
aprire quel gioco arrivò quel gioco orme
un primo privo happy with non lo so io
giochiamo a poche non accenni poche
menti compare battlefield ma.be drogate
o cosa va beh non selena non guarda solo
matt reeves questa un'altra roba
preferiresti essere un ninja può essere
un pirata
tu cosa preferiresti via ti affascinano
di più i pirati ed in india risponde in
base ai tuoi gusti facciamo
[Musica]
80 per cella madonna perché soltanto
questo ciani ninja di così bello
preferiresti avere l'abilità per leggere
la mente o il potere del teletrasporto
so già che pensi che io sia un gran figo
quindi non ho bisogno di regia filamente
zia quindi facciamo molte tracce 50 50 e
addirittura mi sembra esagerato di
questa sera non ha letto cliccato a caso
preferiresti bere un bicchiere di acqua
di mare o un altra roba che ho cliccato
dovresti essere parlando su per me mi
fanno cagare entrambi però tra i due
superman perché non sono messo molto
bene i muscoli ma lei non importa le
importarlo uomo intelligente mi sa che
non sono messo bene
vabbè comunque vita di con tra gli
elementi di controllare il tempo ma
perché non mi dire te mi fai scegliere
dopo che lega e che io ho già cliccato
maledizione vabbè pazienza bello beh
questa era un altro gioco zia e non era
quello che volevo fare era un altro
gioco è chris è questo qui è visto che
bello per sé io faccio sta roba da un
sacco di tempo e la gente lo guarda e si
incazzano sono facili da su star o la
pensate come cazzo è possibile detto non
lo so neanche io zia però bombe favole
virus e quindi stickers perché ma
non è no dovete stare calmi
dovete stare tutti molto calmi cosa è
successo
come ho fatto l'europa per questo modo
di vedere
fatemi vedere freghi sta roba se ho
lanciato il po che ho fatto saltare
tutto col poco tranne una bomba che poi
mi stava per esplodere in faccia e poi
sono entrato no vabbè ragazze sono per
questo dovrei sposarmi idea solo per
questo
il carano hd quindi hd e questo è porca
vacca che grafica di battlefield
sostituti possono accompagnare solo beh
meglio dei fitti delle sue canzoni e non
è un'offesa a via a giocate più grease
con selena mi fa male pure la schiena
affari affari fare così qualche una
carica fa un caldo bestiale oggi non so
se dopo virtuale ci manca solo di fare
di bellissimo in un vulcano se fa caldo
si è messo l'impegno tiziano ha fatto
livello nefasta canzone ai complimenti
qui sicuramente ce l'ha la [ __ ] avrà
della carenza nelle riviste stazioni
sentimentali ma ben avviati piano in
cerca
sono situazioni sentimentali però
complimenti per il bel livello mi sento
proprio emozionato dentro non so come ho
fatto a vivere senza prima domina of
death domino della morte oddio il domino
io detesto penso di dover fare io do
domino vabbè sticazzi non c'è voglia di
aspettare sono una persona che non c'è
voglia di aspettare non faccio la coda
alle poste non guardo neanche il domino
rock swing new nuovo mai visto un
livello che chi sa che a livello è bello
white mai vista una roba del genere
fantastico che bella l'innovazione su
yepes
meno male che c'è questa varietà di
livelli non avrebbe scritto news zio
perché tutto questo comunque non riesco
ancora a farlo nonostante ne abbia fatti
un milione nella mia vita perché
raccomandi è difficile
non guardare ma guardate che faccio
brutte figure il tuo ragazzo fa brutte
figure porca vacca quanto è difficile
questa sentita malissimo dai madonna
fate difficile non ha mai messo così
tanto e centrare un uso non ascoltare
quello che dico che poi pensi male
barcaccia vacca schifosa o abbiamo
un'ora di tempo per questa laiche voglio
dersi in un'ora lo centro e non farvi
fare figure di merda che ci si allena
che riguarda porca eva non sono tanto le
20 mila persone guardano la live da tra
il pezzo di cartone mi guarda là dietro
il problema secondo me se ti impegni
vinci zio solo se solo se esclusivamente
se ti impegni non ci hai voglia a oggi
oggi non ci abbiamo voglia di impegnarci
regis moriamo non c'entriamo i buchi e
[ __ ]
un anno e mezzo da pasta roba grazie
raga caldo fermi un attimo per mese
quando ci ho bisogno di voi non avete
idea di che caldo incredibile fa poi ciò
sta luce che mi spara flash di fascia
bruttissimo cioè a 30.000 siete solo
detto che più vince fa le views case tim
payne te l'ho detto io che faceva le
views lewis se non sai la strategia di
marketing tu non la conosci selena
rimettere la tua faccia nei video da
decina avanti tutti i video che faccio
fra i ragazzi ce la faccio di selena
gomez non mi fa solo lei le views
perfetto
cambiamo livello perché subito già a
cagare il bene comune è che lewis mi
piacesse per carità di dio però prova a
fermarti ecco questo è tipo provare a
fermarsi che non lo faccio mai zia però
perde oggi lo faccio lo greco è visto
come ti amo
ora che troviamo in un unico di spinelli
che vanno neanche a quello che sembra
non finire mai a prescindere ma non
posso fermarmi vista che alle braccia
come faccio spiegami profeta partenza
giusta è perché i primi a mio zio non
tornano posso mai fermarmi come te non
mi spari troppo veloce o salto quarto
beh va beh no ragazzi [ __ ] e in
pose questo è impossibile mi spara
troppo veloce non mi fermo mai the clash
è la madonna quando provi ad importunare
la mia ragazza
le stesse fiera di me
ai diktat di 20 non è mai capito una
balla così a scavalcare le cose con che
fisica perché senza preparando di epici
se non è che puoi pretendere chissà che
mi è rimasto incastrato un kebab alla
ruota ditemi se è possibile che vada
essendoci plastificata stato applicato
su scuola non è più coesa sarà ma va più
veloce non capitoli di casa serve il
razzo attaccato
nulla tv da portare il terrazzo 4 che va
bene senza cipolla più una persona
mutilate bello il suo livello proprio
più allegro dei soliti raga va bene
ferrari e non su ferrari o le questo
capite ecco se avete la roba [ __ ] che
meno facendo questo livello
c'è questo livello azione questo video
in live capite quanto più o meno io ci
metto a fare un livello di resine tipo
un'oretta il registro un'ora e poi
escono me è la fisica di suo gioco è un
optional
quando tipo si è svegliato nel programma
se gioca detto va bene mettiamoci la
fisica perché troppo troppo reale voi va
bene non ho capito ma ok va bene è
importante avere la macchina giusta
sto dicendo per fare è perché io tipo
dura 10 minuti ogni episodio non ci
mette di più un'oretta a fare cioè di
registrazione almeno venete quanto
cimento realmente barca è la schifosa
pensate che che strazio è per meditare
stava buona volta che finisce
[Musica]
ma chi è anche quadrato non so se avete
notato ma il tipo quando ha messo le sue
figlie non ha fatto livello mica era
sotto effetto di cocaina e quanto sono
storte quanto puoi essere stupri acco
per metterle mettere trite santo iddio
c'è proprio neanche l'impegno proprio il
massimo
dottor flip se riusciremo a primo
tentativo mi mettevo in nuotando in live
ragazzi però anche le serie con il
secondo tentativo rimette in moto anni
il live
meno male che non è uscito meno meno
male guarda cioè non è che tutta storta
porca vacca perché ci riprovo mi
chiamasse vedere un ci riuscirò matthew
c'è sempre provato a far cadere la botta
nel buco ma mai ci sono riuscito porca
eva schifosa poi [ __ ] da falco cielo
creduto
nora caperna ci ha ormai ha ormai ci
devo riuscire a la stronza forse riesco
ancora passata tipo di sostanza ecco il
ragazzo
niente aspetta terminati i ragazzi non
riuscirci è bello perfetto bellissimo
coppa era lì proprio e c'è mancato un
vero che non entrava panorami p per il
culo a farmi capire e mi stai prendendo
veramente per il culo zio mayall ho
detto zio enoc e poi mi chiamo
bellissimo nel video di auto live
dell'altra volta avevo di avevo detto in
un momento di ira che ho detto zio zio
con la z maiale su youtube è apparso un
video top 10 bestemmie di youtuber
italiani ho capito che il tuo zio per te
ed io però lo so che gli vuoi che così
tanto bene ma io ho detto zio fratello
non ho detto l'altro e quindi mi danno
ormai per segni attività medico e
bestemmia va bene non è quello con quel
punto dove dove deve deve andare per
essere questo qua a destra però ok mi sa
che ha detto se un po ubriaco è di oggi
se vi si ferma in testa rito allora
c'era mamma proprio che fa le cose
brutte quelle brutte in autostrada ma ma
brutte forti è che porta è una tipo di
impegnare fa così schifo o frate dai mal
è così e penso che ci sia una bella
pagina di noli dall'altra bella è preso
un paio di volte se non riesco pazienza
mi darò all ippica ma devo dire dietro è
caduto in piedi come cazzo è possibile
dai porca vacca fermi la gamba basta mi
sono rotto il cazzo adesso non posso non
averlo negato finché non riesco perché
non è possibile
sapete le questioni di vita o di morte
selena mi sta guardando proprio queste
figure di merda non muoverò non si
arrende io non mi arrenderò re grafica
non riuscirà a farsi st schifo di botto
il film maledetta che avete l'altro nel
video di è più vicino avevo fatto la
prima bozza è arrivato un milione e
seicentomila piuss
non so perché si di venivano così tanto
non è un'idea bravo ok closing
ma tua madre cerebrolesa cav h schifoso
maledetto odio sto gioco la vita sospeso
che c'era questa merda era buono era
buono dai ma allora si fa mostra smart
power a chi credi ma va a far gruppo lo
zio da ma vi chiama non ci posso credere
c'erano veramente non puoi non fa così
schifo sto gioco dai bisogni giusto
sudando e bisogna dire che sto sudando
male ho bisogno di concentrazione non c
è ora ganci però intenzione anche la
neanche togliendo mila e proprio la
concentrazione livello top a ginger cosa
cosa è successo
non ho capito va bene
ma fa niente se incastrata di mortacci
the two ma ora che non c'è verso di di
centrare quel maledetto buco non
ascoltarmi e salerno dove non sentire
ste cose che vivo
no raiano me le barbie giuro su dio che
continua a far suo livello finché non me
ne fa niente
ma l'ex cava schifosa laida maledetta
non sto parlando di tesi a della mamma
di chi ha fatto questo livello maledetto
a tua madre va bene anche così va bene
anche così si cazzi importante che sia
importante centrare il buco anche se lo
centri ma può dirsi guarda guarda ammira
e questo fa di me un uomo mica i muscoli
migali intelligenza mica la bellezza chi
sa fare il botto il flip l'uomo vero
porca vacca l'agro nessuna vita ma posso
metterci mai una vita per farsi livelli
che non ha senso di esistere sta roba
c'è porca vacca io mi impegno per fare
le cose non c'è verso desistere ogni
forma ma poi avevano una velata
aspettano prospettando prima lo sapete
stara a voi non avete idea non ce
l'avete di quanto io sto a montare i
video perché devo tagliare un miliardo
di parti che non mi escono alle volte
tipo facili imposti col no che vedete
che riesco al primo tentativo ma col
cazzo l'esercito più potente divano
fatto i 500 prima ma non sapeva ma non
avete idea di quante volte mi è successo
con caricamento 1 stories dove dico che
sono il live della gente la vede effetto
voi siete sempre i primi a vedere le mie
storie
ok perfetto tra l'altro è semplice per
chi cazzo c'è sempre questa cosa qui
quando apro la guardate incredibile ok
ma perché perché non aprire mai bar ma
in tutte le laico fatto ci starò bruno
zoe ormai fa parte dello schermo c'è
così e così stig attiva
nonostante il caldo aragami li metto le
cuffie perché c'è bisogno di
concentrazione prima ce l'avevo bisogno
bisogno di stare senza perché per cavo
caldo adesso con i confini con centro
triangolo troubles che cosa mi chiedono
ma ci posso credere che ora è possibile
dai [ __ ]
vabbè massima carica oggi una giornata
di merda verrebbe dice cos'è ma voi non
riuscirò mai più quello il problema
perciò però mai più lo sollecita una
volta ma basta c'è riuscito più o meno
ok ma allora si dice la madre che puzza
proprio
dai zio vitasnella non è ancora finita e
se giro porca vacca come fate incastra
dal frate una fermi non elevato
innervato continuo penso che ce la farai
so che me lo sento mi sento mai lo zio
si bravissimo bravissimo di più
spingi come quando tornate degli apparti
rito spingi
[Musica]
tua madre tombino arrugginito [ __ ]
alto livello
ok
fammi un salto decente questo non è un
salto decente questo non è un salto di
gente questo non è un salto decente
questo non è un santo decente
sono ancora vivo se non ti incastrasse
in mezzo ai triangoli di mortacci degli
illuminati no illuminati provare
illuminati e anche anche di gli stormi
non starci e storni attenzione ai non
c'è non c'è non c'è verso di esistere
[ __ ] bacca ma come già bravissimo il
programma bloccato i triangoli se magari
non lo vai riprende il genio aggiungiamo
un [ __ ] genio rega
guarda la mano che mi hai dato gli occhi
in questo livello è stata fondamentale
ti sei meritato il poco in faccia forte
presidenza esempio concerto questo per
sé space
[Musica]
checché se ne parla proprio e vabbè
vabbè madonna cos'è starò è un concetto
è un concerto leggermente pesante
rispetto ai miei soliti cioè quelli dove
vado io
cioè io vado dal polo gang di cava dove
avresti con jazz lunch attiva state che
devo mettere una musica di sottofondo un
po seria per questa questo livello qua
facciamo tipo loro farlo con telefono
perché se non faccio un casino ora lion
facciamo tipo ecco questo speriamo che
sia quello che pensa
[Musica]
dobbiamo prima che mi diano copyright
però è stato un bel concerto zio su
prova naif a 6 greek impossible caps
impossible prova che roba è lì perché
cazzo mi è caduto uno stereo
bello no
non avevo visto l'altra pionere a no no
no no no no come come sono morto c'è
solo il bacino che mi è uscito da del
corpo ma la pazienza ma [ __ ]
ma in realtà è questa piovra che mi dice
mincu la fortissima non solo quello a
quanto pare parecchio anche chi punta ma
dai
[Musica]
quando il voglia è ma non non vuole
disturbare ci vogliono 8 quando lei
voglia ti svegli fenice quando vuoi per
carità di dio tranquillo è un po si va
data una per cento far calare il
bordello cazzo l'impossibile è questo
con le bombe
una però più o meno arca [ __ ]
no dai l'ho presa trio lo prende sul
serio stavolta stata la presa ma era un
po smembrato 15 st prima l'avevo presa
capo devo fare lì già per aggiungere st
mi chiama sono ero ancora vivo però non
dai zio l'ho presa perché è quello il
problema c'è scusa di prendere una mina
di testa non è proprio il massimo
gesù
no no no
perrotta schifosa ma ritarda no a dio
non così se riuscissi a saltare ste
cazzo di mine allora tranquilla penso io
mo lo chiamo personaggio c'è ma neanche
sa neanche non è piega spinta normale
dobbiamo non c'è verso
come ho fatto fermi un attimo lucera
lentino fattore che non sosterrà lenti 7
non c'era lenti asi slowear cazzo non lo
sapeva c'è come come cosa qua quanto con
pochi fps ralenti di happy with vabbè
lasciamo perdere
abbiamo cioè un altro imputare a
domicilio con imposti ormai devo devo
try this is my christmas domani devo
fare un arena challenge con me stesso
raga sempre con dei voglia di farvi
vincere farlo bambino scritto la carità
di dio non c'è o non c'è volte in cui io
non riesco a schiattare
[Musica]
diceva non c'era volta in cui a vincere
il primo salto impossibile devo sempre
morire in qualche modo in passivo già
quarti abbiamo finito l'impossible di
oggi praticamente è un pene quello che
vogliono ballare qualsiasi cosa sia l'ho
preso ma mi sono staccato le braccia non
è stato proprio il massimo non guardare
selena quello bene è un bene quello in
guardando web
ricorda che puoi vedere queste cose ha
rimbalzato sul pene cazzo a devo toccare
devo toccare terra e poi dove di tornare
su ok non guardare bene selena guarda
porca eva troppo in alto tesi questa
buona
[Musica]
devo fare tutto la sinistra che siano
vede progetto era un pennello rigoglio
infatti youtube censura di brutto ma sti
cazzi tanto siamo in live view versus
john cena quello è john cena questo è
john cena per quale motivo dovrebbe
essere john cena questa
secondo me mi sono fatto più male io che
lui a giudicare dalla posizione della
mia testa però dettagli the pigeon
course the pigeon un litigio the west
grande grande grande due radio dove sei
no no no no jacques le pigeon non
salvarlo ma fatela che kate the pigeon
hai colto watch dovevo stare attento
alle carte ci ha scritto per terra la
merda this is minchiate non so come si
chiama con la roba ma miseri minchiata
ok perfetto usiamo pure era ruota come
mezzo di locomozione e non c'è più le
cose lo devo andare così per forza porca
vacca non li dietro già sta facendo però
è mi sa che quel punto non lo passo che
creò questo dubbio è poi non lo so
magari me così mi sa che non lo passo
ricalcano devo uscire alla cagata
difficile magari non schiantarmi sul
primo muro che trovo però possiamo farlo
porca vacca ceramica per terra non
dimentica infatti non mi ricordavo
com'ero morto
devo saltare la mina fermi tutti che chi
è poi stato di previsione il piccione di
bello che voi abbiate mai visto
cosa c era in quel pane al parco ok
cagate di piccione per terra franco
effetto l'occhio non sono arrivato tanto
diverso da prima e unica roba che cioè
il mio mezzo di locomozione e intatto
almeno quello
però adesso de popolare con un ufficio
c'è la scrittura hi macs fly like a
pillon pigione francese comunque c'era
in realtà non è francese ma per me
fratello nonno 6 giu
ma perché stai cercando nonno ah eccolo
ci sono dei mini pc per terra
le figlie de peage un made by matteo
leone ciao marte voler one matteo del
real potato che problemi che affliggono
matteo che scuola elementare hai fatto
il quale istituto psichiatrico brno le
persone come te fammi sapere lasciare un
commento qui sotto grazie
basta poi dopo pizza delivery lui lo
luigi luigi pizzi l'orage i maori o
scazzi si chiama luigi nigi a questa non
è bella
secondo me non ha neanche troppa fame la
zia lì vabbè si chiama ne facciamo a
fare una piega ben michele che
danneggiano mi piace un sacco
magari falle con la bicicletta ancora
annusata ce l'ho usato solo una volta
per grafica cia sul livello che c'è
batta il primo ha mai visto delle rocce
così ben definisce questo qua ha passato
le giornate a definire bene le rocce
sentire indicando il cazzo
davanti ok andiamo a muovere il culo
prima che mi spiacerà morire o ma che
affidata a esso livello ma fermi questo
livello della vita come che era solo
nella seconda pagina dei livelli più
beni votati micheli velo più quello
abbia mai visto che già sono al come ha
fatto bene le rocce vari dettagli guarda
i dettagli delle rovine con gli scratch
sul muro che il videogioco di tomb
raider può accompagnare sopra veramente
figo ora l'acqua per terra che figo
ora che ha fatto benissimo a livello
cioè sono emozionato per una volta ho
giocato a una roba seria
vediamoli del budget si livelli si
profila a ok
lei mi the cure e gli ormai cult va bene
casa a sto punto con gatto fai tu ok
sembrava gringott di harry potter
perché devo tenermi aver seguito ten
prova bello
manca solo un po di effetti sonori
proprio il resto figo anche era quello
di prima
cioè non lo stelo riconosciuto dalla
bella faccia che già era quello del
primo livello
hong kong schmaler hawks o ai media
brown sembra è come di questi sono gli
uomini mica justin bieber canta
sbagliato ragazzotto zia
vabbè che non sta con piazza che sta the
week end pezzo di merda di sbagliato nel
paese sbagliato tutto e quella questi
sono i veri muscoli mica quelli che
c'era the week end io oltre 2 ti faccio
fuori del lunedì fino alle venerdì zio
ma ecco cinque volte tanto
lo swing one facciamo rock swing stai
calma innanzitutto zio e agli spasmi sto
personale di ogni tanto perfetto media
nomi riuscirà mai più una presa così
bella in un flop swing ma io l'ho fatto
in là ok bb donan una news
ecco non la volevo darmelo sto per dire
ma era meglio
questo caso solo per dire i rokes ling
sono i livelli che ha visto riprova di
più perché moglie un sacco di volte ma
può tantissime più degli impossible e
quindi fare un rock swing in una live è
un suicidio perché non so quanto tempo
ci mettono prima di finirlo però loro
sticazzi come volevo dire quella frase
sono morto quindi funziona tutta la
barca
no perché non c'è i piani per prendere
le cose come te le fai le seghe si beh
no ma tonache che salvataggi incredibile
oggi o terza volta e ultima e non lo
faccio più poi vedevi azzeccare si prova
posso tenere a nero vi prego benedetto
di gesù mare cavalcano come come come
cazzo come ma come faccio a farsi e
cambia a livello nomi spicca la pagina
almeno quello porca vacca schifosa
maledetta rama ce ne fosse una di volta
che riesco a fare cosa c'entra una c'è
un'incredibile c'era io non ho paura non
ho lo rifaccio mi sento mi sento
umiliato da me stesso non lo so ecco
questo livello
questo tipo a livello di prima però con
una grafica un po più merdosa ecco this
is a un hub nei cross
esattamente come diceva tipo di prima
luke ti lascio al parco e fai il bravo è
ecco il karma iscritti in darkness i
goti per cen to find something ok
trovai in questa caverna e diventa
sempre più buio man mano che va giù che
figata
va bene
ok
caos e freddo sono mica mi cadono quando
mi cadono le rocce perfetta tendiamo
sempre più però ragazze iniziano a
vedersi pi niente io che ci posso fare
breaking di small rocks uil trick debord
del tufo
ma scusa ma io c'ho una luce da qualche
parte una torcia a eccola sì ho capito
ma con la prendo io che posso andare
avanti avevo visto ma io mica posso
lasciare zio non è che possa lasciare la
bici se no perché ne vada avanti cioè
kagami frate anno le chiedevo perché
devo cliccare con il mouse
forse devo cliccare con il mouse e la
che non lo so e provo ma siamo non
riesco ps
ok che aspetto lo prendi no ok quindi
devo andare a rompere il muro dietro
che belli questi livelli di è infatti ok
che stava morendo così
[ __ ] porca vacca veloce zio veloce
che appunta nas tifoso sapevo da 20 gas
sticazzi spider man reflex è poco i
riflessi di spider man show bravo bravo
stavo leggendo cosa c'era scritto l'ho
fatto in tempo a leggere che mi hanno
ucciso c'è scritto finalmente miei
sconfitto spider man in questo caso si
chiama canzone si è fatta anche un po
male lo prende la moneta dove vai zio
prende l'iniziativa va bene bello
livelli di spiderman rock swim troppi
swing vuol dire proprio notare ma ma ma
ma ci credete
come non avete idea di quanti l'email io
taglio che finiscono così cioè non ce
l'avete ogni volta che arriva alla fine
mi si sta calpesta per qualche motivo
non lo so vabbè gen in the box dove
fatto che lì nei box rivano jamie lynn
box almeno oggi un livello l'ho fatto
senza morire 20 volta all'inizio
perfetto pikachu tv gamer 123 doveva
essere il mio secondo dick men nickname
ragazzi io mi chiamo fabio mi chiamo
pikachu tv gamer meno male che mi sono
chiamato famiglia che però era un po un
problema in passivo 98 è che se no ci
sono preso bene o l'impossible dove
cazzo sono andato ho sbagliato non ho
capito niente io
ecco appunto anche tosca che cavalca
jolo mi sa che sono morte o terminati o
sono ancora vivo ma chi lo raggiunge il
traguardo così dai dai dai dai del nuovo
era giusto perché come faccio a schivare
stia al piano impossibile raga a meno
che non faccia tipo così viva le teste
ce l'ho fatta ragazzo perfetto next time
no non ne faccio più di imposti qualche
fare figure di merda sono riuscito a
finirli tutti che aveva in questo
momento il video di tutti in alto
sembrava che guardando un po romana
fatto un orgasmo mamme che state
ascoltando i films non è un porno happy
feet che più o meno la stessa cosa e
proprio ok no no si perfetto ma allora
cioè dei problemi spiega mi ha dato non
è traguardi mi sono sempre a guardo
prende dai zio era convinto ci potesse
ancora muovere vabbè allora qual è il
tuo problema dio qualche cosa ti hanno
picchiato da piccolo
ti davano gli schiaffi forte sul culo
facciano bene torno da di più forte
stato provato un pezzo di carne lì
perché a ecco perché devo aggrapparmi a
una persona ma tu stai scherzando
ma porca [ __ ] le difficilissime
tradisco buco e non riesca a centrarlo
sto books elena non si sa se ne vantava
di avere orca vacca un'ora e mezza la fa
sta roba
grazie grazie ragazzi grazie a tutti
meli merito questi miei quasi 4 milioni
iscritti botta flip
grazie a tutti basta finito freeform se
lasciamo fare qual era quello del
balance your baby ok aspetta farmaci ce
la posso fare è che dovresti barca
acquistano grazie a tutti i ragazzi sono
riusciti a fare molti più livelli
consiglio faccio di solito almeno ce lo
dicono i dati da 50 minuti più o meno
quasi un'ora ma vi giuro che non ho mai
fatto così tanti livelli che cosa che
succede a è un ladro quello a uccidi il
ladro va bene
non proprio ci riprovo
mi sa che non è tutta questa forza nelle
braccia non stava scherzando mai
contraddire non certo per lui va
se gliene frega un cazzo a lui c'è una
spada le maglie ne frega niente non ne
frega un cazzo va bene così poco
youtubers certi cani cosa se non mettono
famiglie di offendere ma player
c'è anche una foto io manco al martelli
vanno schierò tutti trovarne tranne io e
basta più di pai dove fa vj è solo
perché non c'è 55 milioni di iscritti
non mi mettete questa mafia ma dai siamo
veramente perfetto andiamo avanti
lasciamo perdere dai board cosa su ci
accuserà cosa che non capisco
[Musica]
quella è una piscina perfetto così
matrix 95 per cento impossible bassa
così imposto misure il film erotico la
il gol n
in possible va bene ragazzi facciamo gli
ultimi due
facciamo gli ultimi due che si facevano
tipo un'oretta di happy days in totale
facciamo
una roba decente almeno a new york boss
non è decente boat of it non è decente
per cercare dei centri velette cento
scritto livello decente ma zio che sarà
118 913 questo non è un livello decente
zio non è che se chiami un livello
decente
così è decente devi anche farlo bene
tipo vai newest amici diventa grande
impariamo a fare un po i livelli vostri
haga che magari esce escono bene cosa
che non è mai successa proverà ad essi
sono di giugno abbiamo fa vj seguito dj
possibile basso avg pro ma questo fa
vice diventa grande fratello show 22
anni non è che sono pubblico ciao fare
le congratulazioni per i 3 milioni di
iscritti usa internet explorer sto tizio
prove benvenuto la mio parkour
le regole sono semplici salta sui
palazzi per ogni volta che sai diventerà
se diventerà sempre più incasinato fabi
se non riesci a vincere va indietro sono
l'esca pc ragazzo mio ma con chi bacon
chi pensi di viale parlare qua ci ho
giocato è più rispetto
il più tempo della mia vita che giocate
per il tiro più gioco più avviso degli
happy vis che bolt in cui sono andato in
bagno nella mia vita poiché non riesca a
far livello così ti pare zio ti pare zio
tiriamo indietro perché non riesco a
farlo andiamo come dice lui
non risco andare indietro nel che fa
niente non possono scendere e salire
rimango qua
che ti avevo detto grazie sei molto
gentile zio apre comunque farlo tanto
non è che sia così difficile zio di
saltare il primo e due tasti ma perché
sono impedito e nei videogiochi però c è
una considerazione di me un po bassa
frate non è vero è perfetta non puoi
arrivarci arrampica di a like spider man
like anguille
[Musica]
dodici anni fa stava bene meglio tardi
che mai si prova questo poiché prova
questo proprio questo se non dice lui ma
vige non ce la fai è impossibile ma cade
appiccate da solo
volevi porca vacca veloce a taiz va bene
va bene conta meritoria e li malfoy
chiami anche perché ti chiami malfoy di
alcol e veronica misura difficile però
siccome c'ha posso fare ragazze
l'impegno stavo scherzando lo schermo
non sai strano scherzo
dai che santo era facciamo la mia nonna
fatto salda meglio zio
l'affetto perfetto è esattamente il
pubblico e non dovevi andare in giro o
la tua madre morta sul marciapiede
[Musica]
sposami donna sposami
vabbè ragazzi facciamo l'ultimo di today
che bello che dopo non devo editare il
viso perché l'avete già visto ha
ritagliato un sacco di roba ma siamo in
live posso fare i tagli in live amici e
questo è bello ti credo sia un sacco
bridge 66 per cento il prossimo e quiz
doyle
non è vero non c'è un quiz hai fatto al
nostro quiz
ma sai come si fanno i quinti dio ci
sono le domande di questa eco troll mag
ex lege non sei capace facevo lingua fa
[Musica]
bjg già scarmoncin ha già oggi già scar
non cina che va i livelli di happy with
facciamo tipo quanta roba quanta troppa
scelta ciò ridge versus tecniche di 120
posti tempo seconda tappa 100 gr fare
l'ultimo a livello ragazzi come
impossible che almeno faccio vedere ai
ripari che io posso fare anche i livelli
miei vostri con non sono quelli degli
altri
visto come sono bravo a caracas di cosa
[Musica]
stavo scherzando non riesco a farli mi
posi facciamo un altro livello ragazzi
culo and vagina pippo are the best
facciamo una roba di culo and vagina due
belli questi livelli di culo and vagina
un sacco di qualità a questo gioco che
mancava
ma allora mi fate capire una cosa anche
problemi avete oggi col botto ora non
riuscite a fare dei botto run decenti
perché era riuscita a mettere le
bottiglie dritte siete tutti i drogati
oggi avete più punto se dovrei animarci
guarda distorto che mio nonno quel
parkinson
senti culo and pagina è una leggere due
è una versione trasmette zio o riesco
utile anche a cercare
[Musica]
o o
o
no
ora ci credo funzione anche le braccia
per trascinarmi dai zio stai zitto eyes
bravo spingi miraggio in culo se
riuscissi a prendere porca [ __ ] non
le braccia per trascinarmi laga insomma
mi sembra di essere uno sgombro dai
sparami porca vacca
ma perché va indietro bravo no semmai
una giusta eventi sbagliate come tua
madre
si va da sinistra a destra mi frega un
cazzo basta che mi sparano
colpiscimi maledetta palla
c'è in 3d
ho fatto prima
porca [ __ ]
probabilmente rifacendo lo avevo già
finito 20 volte però sempre allora
fratello lo so che c'è la mamma [ __ ]
per prime 1 ott hi fi trascinare a
destra o ti fai trascinare sinistra non
può è un po decine di cazzo ora destro
alla sinistra porca [ __ ] ray e posso
stare qua tutto il giorno quando la
destra ea destra continua ad essere che
poi va a sinistra sinistra però non
andare a destra
tua madre succhia i tombini in
autostrada morta porca [ __ ] eva
caschi foga concentrations lega ad ora
volti schiaffi in faccia gli darei a
quest'uomo porca vacca non avete idea
non sa neanche other dritto cioè che la
rai
ok vai con gesù ok perfetto no
da destra fuck yeah
ragazzi miei direi che basta direi che
però oggi è più il soldato il suo anche
questo lo scratch qui ha dato il suo
perché sono troppo contento ogni volta
di giocare pensi mi sento mi sento
fantastico niente raga direi che
possiamo chiudere qui il video di oggi è
stato bello giocare più easy driver meno
me lo devo montare pensate voi che
dopotutto so strazio io quando registra
il più hills dove montarlo pensate
quanto gioisco poi molti si chiedono
perché o di happy c'è un motivo se state
tutta la giornata giocare a sta roba e
poi non riuscite a fare livelli perchè
come avete visto livelli fanno veramente
schifo
poi devo stare pure a montarlo selena ce
la sta facendo alla stanno schiacciando
va beh spero spero che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi io concludo con l'episodio stai
ferma che famiglia
concludo concluso pd episodio ringrazio
selena per aver partecipato a questo
video sia stata una barca bach e mi sa
che se ero va bene ci vediamo un file
altro sena che sicuramente sei capace
per la mia auto non ti vedo carica zia
sempre morta oggi si è svegliata male
vabbè io chiedo poi ragazzi è stato
bello vi giuro problema che non sono
capaci a fare tris il live preferì
questo provo un miliardo di volte però
sappiate che ci ho messo un sacco di
impegno e l'impegno a volte conta tanto
quindi non mi giudicasse quello che
viene sempre più ragazzi serena
concludiamo cose
il momento mi piace anche al disagio che
come vietata dalla descrizione saperci
di skater in ci vediamo il prossimo
video belle ragazze